hey 42 here 20/20 has already earned a
dreadful reputation World War II nearly
began devastating fires have swept
throughout the world and now we have an
historic pandemic on our hands and we're
not even a third of the way through the
year yet but it's also becoming the year
of something else introverts with a
significant portion of the world's
population under some sort of lockdown
staying at home and being unsociable is
the new normal in fact in most cases
it's the law introverts around the world
are silently laughing at the struggling
extroverts who are wondering what mental
superpowers these less socially active
people possess partying shopping and
other general social activities are now
a distant memory something we probably
now realize we all took for granted even
popping to the shops to buy essential
supplies and going for a walk is now
strictly limited and for the most
vulnerable in our society banned
altogether social distancing isn't a
choice anymore it's essential but how
will self isolation change us and how
will it change the world for the better
or for the worse
well if history is anything to go by
this year's global quarantine will
change the world forever and perhaps in
many positive ways isolation isn't new
you could even call it biblical as an
account of separating out infected
people to prevent the spread of disease
can be found in writings dating back to
the seventh century BC or perhaps even
earlier it states in the Book of
Leviticus the priest is to isolate the
infected person for seven days on the
seventh day the priest is to examine him
and if he sees that the saw is unchanged
and has not spread in the skin he is to
isolate him for another seven days
fast-forwarding to the year 706 and
isolation of the sick became mandatory
especially with illnesses such as
leprosy during the Middle Ages so-called
her colonies started to spring up
everywhere especially in Europe and
India but this was just an attempt at
separating the already sick from the
healthy isolating the virus or bacteria
from a potential new host this work when
people were showing symptoms sure but
what about the asymptomatic cases the
people who were not showing any symptoms
yet but was still unknowingly spreading
the disease with an incubation period of
between two to six days the Black Death
of bubonic plague gave its host ample
time to go about their days unnoticed
from the point of being infected -
showing the first signs of the deadly
disease after which there was roughly a
thirty seven day interval from infection
to death the black death was the most
devastating pandemic ever to be recorded
in human history and resulted in the
deaths of up to 200 million people
across Eurasia as you can imagine maybe
a little too easily these days death was
everywhere plague pits were dogging
villages towns and cities for the
citizens to carry and dump their dead in
- probably infecting themselves in the
process it was clear that just isolating
the visibly sick wasn't going to do the
trick and during the second wave of the
plague in 1448 the Venetian Senate
isolated incoming ships for forty days
as an attempt who stopped newly infected
people from disembarking this 40-day
isolation seems to be an effective way
of handling outbreaks of the plague and
gave birth to a word which we have been
using quite a lot recently
quarantine coming from the Venetian word
quarantine er meaning forty days of
course we now know that the bubonic
plague was predominantly spread through
the bite of infected fleas and rarely
through human to human contact but at
the time it was highly suspected that
the disease was spread through the air
by what was known as a miasma to put it
simply bad air it was said that my
asthma's were characterized by a foul
smell which to be fair could have just
been the cause
the sense of people throwing buckets if
she tapped their windows but since
medical science wasn't really a thing
back then their nose was all they had to
go on and if these plague-ridden people
were going to be filling the air of
their smelly rotting pus-filled bubo x'
it was clear what had to be done social
gatherings had to be stopped over a
hundred or so years later in 1603 under
the union of the crowns James the first
received a sudden promotion as the King
of England and Ireland even though he
was from Scotland but that's another
story which you can read about in my
book however before he barely had the
tans plunked the crown onto his head
another devastating outbreak of bubonic
plague was sweeping throughout London
eager to have a significant amount of
subjects to rule over James the first
thought it best to stop the spread of
the disease one of his first actions as
monarch was to issue a book of orders a
set of rules to be obeyed by the public
with the hope that it would prevent the
spread of the plague laws were put in
place stating that houses were to be
closed for up to six weeks if one of the
inhabitants became sick and that if they
ventured into the community they should
mark their clothes so as to warn others
that they were infected similar to how
today some men adorn a man button to
warn others that they're easily offended
another measure established was that
theatres were to be closed for fears
that the plague was spread through the
crowds it didn't help that the
authorities weren't overly fond of the
theater to begin with too much
cross-dressing encompass for their
liking a preacher at the time sternly
stated that the cause of plagues is sin
and the cause of sin is plays ultimately
this meant that theaters were one of the
first to be closed and between 1603 and
1613 the globe and over London play
houses were shot for more than 60% of
the time this means that a certain
playwright at the time who you may have
heard of had a lot of free time on his
hands during this period William
Shakespeare wrote some of his most
renowned plays forced into self
isolation due to quarantine restrictions
Shakespeare took quilted paper and
produce some of his most famous dark and
best pieces plays such as a fellow King
Lear Macbeth Antony and Cleopatra the
list goes on Shakespeare made many
references to disease under death in
these plays most likely drawing
inspiration from the world outside his
windows in King Lear the king Rapha
harshly he calls his daughter a plague
saw an embossed carbuncle in my
corrupted blood making reference to the
nasty enlarged lymph nodes and
predominant symptom of the bubonic
plague if it weren't for the lockdown of
London would he have ever written these
works of literary gold or would have he
been too busy with the mundane
day-to-day runnings of his popular
Playhouse company I can probably guess
about a dysentery a civil war and a
beheading later charles ii took the
throne it was summer in 1665 and the
last major epidemic of the bubonic
plague had just hit England it would
come to be known as the Great Plague of
London and stole the lives of a quarter
of London's population in just 18 months
and then rather luckily the very next
year the Great Fire of London hit which
burnt down most of the city so let's
hope that's not yet to come for us
charles ii had a particular interest in
science and recognized the vital
importance of proper social distancing
this let him measures that are not too
unfamiliar with our own today aside from
keeping the sick at home along with
their entire household the government's
supplied food to the house pound so as
to ensure they had no reason to leave
their home in shops merchants would ask
their customers to drop their coins into
dishes of vinegar to sterilize them
before they purchased anything the 17th
century version of contactless payments
if you like all public gatherings
including funerals were halted and
notably Oxford and Cambridge
University's closed their doors students
were sent home to continue their studies
and the young man named Isaac returned
to his family's estate where
he self isolated himself I am of course
referring to one of the most influential
scientists of all time Sir Isaac Newton
and little did he know this time of
isolation would be his most productive
years yet whilst taking a leisurely
stroll in the garden an apple tree yes
that apple tree caught his attention he
mused that the force which brought
apples to the ground mustn't be limited
to a certain distance why not as high as
the moon he is alleged to have said to
himself and just like that the theory of
gravity was soon born in 1667 he
returned to Cambridge bringing his
theories with him two years later he was
a professor it may not be as fun as the
anecdote of an apple hitting him on the
head but it's still an incredible story
and brings with it an important message
when we take a step back from normal
life we're able to see things from a new
perspective it's like an extreme version
of why it's easier to think of great
ideas in the shower distraction from the
normality and routine of life gives our
brains a break so our subconscious can
work on a problem more creatively in its
own time all the free time during
quarantine probably helps as well but
dispense a question with most of the
world being held on to some sort of
quarantine and isolation right now what
does our future hold
is there a teenager currently stuck at
home and in a desperate bid to get some
peace and quiet from his family as
learning how to code for the first time
those first lines of code could one day
transform into the next world changing
technological advance is aboard
scientists self isolating and in the
meantime experimenting with a home DNA
sequencing kit potentially unlocking the
secrets to immortality or at the very
least making us all glow in the dark is
a teacher finally following his dreams
of writing a novel which one day could
be a number one bestseller and become a
classic the probabilities are truly
endless and in these uncertain times the
prospect that the fallout could be a
bright one brings a lot of hope but
there is one thing that is certain one
undeniable benefit that this mass
earth quarantine will produce
technological advances you probably
noticed it yourself everything is now
being done online even more so than ever
before just a few months ago the force
of working from home every day attending
virtual events and still being able to
have close meaningful relationships
through a screen seemed a little too
futuristic for 2020 but we're here now
and we're doing it I'm not saying all of
this is necessarily good for mental
health because it isn't but you can bet
there will be enormous technological
progress to emerge in the years to come
because of it
and we've all done this after just a
couple of months of being forced to find
a way through this chaos and with the
somewhat limited technology we had to
hand we are about to experience a
technological revolution the future is
here so why not start that new hobby
write that novel or learn that new skill
you might not get another chance quite
like this for the rest of your life
let's hope you don't but you could just
change the world thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon it
really helps me to continue to make
these videos the links in a description
also if you want to get your hands on a
first edition signed copy of my new book
stick a flag in it a thousand years of
bizarre history from Britain and beyond
then head on over to unbound publishing
the links in the description and get
yours today thank you